David Boder: [In English] Spool 9-45A and 9-45B. It had some irrelevant material on the start. Possibly in duplication a, um...previously used wire was used again. The spool is for the time being 9-45A, containing the...interview with a...Polish, English-speaking marine, who trains Jewish sailors and fisherman, and 9-45B the beginning of the interview with Mr. Bramson at the ORT school. There is some other irrelevant material on the spool—apparently the apparatus, how it often happened was demonstrated to some visitors at the place of interview before privacy could be obtained with the actual interviewee.
David Boder: What is your name sir?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Feneger [?].
David Boder: Feneger [?].
[first name unknown] Feneger: Feneger [?]. F...F-E—
David Boder: That’s all right. You are a Frenchman?
[first name unknown] Feneger: No I am Polish.
David Boder: You are Polish?
[first name unknown] Feneger: My father was come from of [?] Poland to Berlin. And I lived in Berlin.
David Boder: Aha, and you lived in Berlin?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Ya.
David Boder: Now I understand that you are now with the ORT?
[first name unknown] Feneger: I...we are working with the ORT and with other organizations in order to form a Jewish Marine.
David Boder: A Jewish Marine?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Marine, yes.
David Boder: And where do you have your headquarters?
[first name unknown] Feneger: We have our headquarters in London.
David Boder: In London?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Yes, it’s a Zebulon...Zebulon organization.
David Boder: Yes.
[first name unknown] Feneger: A Palestinian sea-faring organization...
David Boder: Yes...
[first name unknown] Feneger: A Palestinian sea-faring organization who works, who works in London and in Palestine and in the United States, in the States and they were formed there, they were formed there the Marine...
David Boder: Yes. Are you in Marseille, stationed now?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Now? No. I am in Paris here.
David Boder: You are here in Paris. What are you the general-director or something?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Yes, the technical director.
David Boder: The technical director, now tell me what are you really doing? For instance I understand you have a marine school in Marseille.
[first name unknown] Feneger: Yes, we have twenty-seven people there.
David Boder: Yes and what are you training them?
[first name unknown] Feneger: We are training fishery...for fisheries.
David Boder: For fisheries?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Yes.
David Boder: Yes, and...
[first name unknown] Feneger: We are buying boats and we are training them as French fisherman.
David Boder: Oh.
[first name unknown] Feneger: And French instructors...for nine months and then they will go to sea and for the fisheries of the high—great sea, you know?
David Boder: Yes...uh...deep-sea fishing?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Deep-sea fishing.
[first name unknown] Feneger: Then they will go to Palestine.
David Boder: Yes. Now tell me are you training marines also for other purposes than fishery?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Yes, for navigation. For the Marine...
David Boder: Generally...in other words you are training Jewish seamen.
[first name unknown] Feneger: Jewish seaman, yes.
David Boder: Aha.
[first name unknown] Feneger: And with the collaboration of the Palestine school of Zebulon.
David Boder: Oh, the Zebulon? What is the Zebulon school in Palestine?
[first name unknown] Feneger: Zebulon school in Palestine is the same school as we are here forming [unintelligible] fishery and the merchant marine.
David Boder: A merchant marine.
[first name unknown] Feneger: Merchant marine.
David Boder: Yes...merchant marine.
[first name unknown] Feneger: And an instructor from Palestine will come here.
David Boder: When? To the ORT convention?
[first name unknown] Feneger: No, um.... To our school...[wire break]
David Boder: . . . your students. And do you have only men at your...[wire break]...and do you have already graduates?
[first name unknown] Feneger: No, no, no. We are beginning...not quite yet.
David Boder: You are just beginning and the plan is to create a Jewish Marine.
[first name unknown] Feneger: A Marine, yes.
David Boder: Well, I think that is very interesting.
David Boder: This concludes spool 9-45A. An interview with Mr. Fenger in English, an instructor in the new formed—or newly formed—navigation school which had its branches in Paris. It was the Zebulon school. And in France and, I understand even in England. Chicago, November the 14th 1950, Boder. This concludes Spool 9-45A and eh,...on another spool we have 9-45B the beginning of the interview with Mr. Bramson in Russian.